みなさんこんにちは
今日は僕らの青春大革命というタイトルでお話をさせてもらおうと思います
宜しくお願いします
早速ですが皆さん青春とは何でしょうか
青春と聞いて何を思い浮かべますか
ちなみに僕は聖州をエンジョイできていません
さあなぜでしょうか
彼女がいないからです
今まで彼女が出来たことがありません
今日この後アフターパーティーだとかブレイクタイムだとかありますのでそれにですね
この映像は今世界同時生中継中ということで
はいでホームページでものちょっと見れるということなのでもうしわければぜひ
コンタクトを取ってくださればいいなと思います
でもせ真斗はレンアイだけではありません
長谷まみれになりながら
泥まみれになりながら仲間と一つの勝利を目指す
部活
他にも共に衝突をするかもしれないケンカをするかもしれない
それでも一つのものを作り上げていく学校行事
委員会活動だったり生徒会活動だったり青春というのにはいろいろな側面があると思い
ます
しかし
僕らの青春には敵がいます
さあ何でしょうか
兵士たちです
偏差値をあげなきゃ
有名大学に行かないと
もっと勉強しないと
松蘭ダミー五芒星に将来は一部企業でも
内申点が足りない
これが僕らの現実ですこんなことで頭がいっぱい
高校生というのはこれからの人生を歩んでいくうえで人となる
とても重要な器官ですしかしその時にもっと有意義な時間の使い方やもっと価値のある
ことはないのでしょうか
もしそれがあればそうするべきだと僕は思います
その提案するのがこの国らの青春大革命です
青春大革命とは
社会の物差し書名東
方向性のアクティブ革命この2つの要素で成り立っています
特に今日は高校生のアクティブ革命についてお話をしていこうと思いますので一緒に
ワクワクドキドキしていただいて革命の一方
今日この場で皆さんと一緒に歩みだすだろうなと思っています
では社会の武蔵各メーカー
一昔前を考えてみてください
中卒で高校に行ってもいないのに
総理大臣がそれ大事なれたそんな時代がありました
そう田中角栄さんですじゃあ今はどうでしょうか
漢字が読めないそんな指でバッシングされて内閣の支持率が下がってしまう
そんなことがあります
政治家に想定よりに必要なのは何でしょうかリーダーシップ判断力
政治力
そういうものであるはずなのに
社会が偏差値学力そういったものに囚われているばかりに本当に必要なものだし
そういったものを見失っているのではないでしょうか
行動力だったり集団の行動ができるかどうか
脚力があるかどうか一般教養があるかどうか様々な
偏差値以外にも評価するべき点人間にとって必要な部分というのは必ずあるはずです
また大学としてもさまざまな要素がまた企業としてもいろんなことができる人は様々な
能力を
スキルを持った人がきっと必要なのでは
ないでしょうか
大学の求める人材
企業の求める人材というのは必ずしも偏差値だけではありません
ですからもちろん偏差値は必要なでは必要だとは思いますがそれ以外のスキルを
高校生の家に付けることができれば日本という国は様々なキーをたくさんいますけれど
もそういったところに優秀な高校生配
しですね国際社会で通用するようなそんな風になっていくんじゃないかと
もっともっと羽ばたいて
いろいろな好きになる素晴らしい高校生がその気に入っていくことによってどんどん
どんどん日本がさらに発展していくと僕はそう思っています
高校生の茶会の物差しか決めというのは偏差値という物差しだけではなくそれ以外の
ところについてももっともっと評価してほしいとそういった話です
えっと
続きまして高校生のアクティブ額面
こっちの方もっとたくさんお話ししようと思っています
高校生のアクティブ革命ということなんですけども今の高校生は僕のまあかなり主観な
のかもしれませんけども
地区へとそれが参考書は彼女
塾や図書館の地震室がデート先と
手汗とま首のナビだと戦いながら苦しい日々を過ごさなければならない
多くの高校生はそうなんじゃないかなと思っていますけども
まあそんな状況を打破したある一つの例を今日は紹介したいと思います
主人公は a 君ですちょっと a 君を紹介しましょう
当時高校1年生コミュニケーションが苦手です
趣味は鉄道特技は時刻表南紀と卓球です
そんな a 君
高校に入学し卓球部に入りました
勉強と部活に追われる日
簡単とした日々が続き夏休みに入ります夏休みも
塾と部活のはれ2学期も同じような日々が続いていくと思っていた
しかしそこで b 国であります
big は夏休みにたいのですね山岳民族のアカ族とラフ族の村にホームステイをしに
行っていて国際協力というものに目覚めていました
それで名古屋でも何かをしたいとそれで a 君をはじめ多くの高校生をそっていたん
ですね
その時 a 君は触れてこう思いました
そんなのは無駄じゃないか大学受験に何が遊吟あるんだ
そんなの企業は求めていなそんなことをやったってただのおままごとだ
僕には必要ない勉強の方が大切だ
しかし b 9の強い勧め等
周りの仲間のがやると言ったので b 君
一緒に村仲間と共にですね団体を設立することにしました
いちばん初めにあったのは b 君が立ち上げましたので
b 君がタイの山岳民族の山奥で出会った子どもたちが街の様子を知らなかったという
ことでぜひ
町の嘘を知ってほしいだから修学旅行に連れて行ってあげようということで現地の
ngo と協力してそれでまずお金を集めることにしました
募金パネルだったりだとか募金箱だったりそういったものをみんなで作ったりとかして
実際に街頭募金を行いその資金が集まってその時 a 君はこう言いました
俺も山岳民族の村言ってやるそしてこの修学旅行は俺が引率するんだ
ちなみに a 君今まで海外に行ったことがありませんでした
今まで海外に行ったことがないのにも関わらず
卓球も鉄道もないそんなところへ行こうとしてしまったんですね
その a 君はこの間の鋭針足の時に実際に耐えに行ってきて無事
修学旅行を引率して帰ってきましたこれについては新聞などのメディアでも取り上げ
られ非常にう僕もうらやましいなと思うんですけども
もう一度振り返っていますいままでの a 君はその時は当時高校1年生で
コミュニケーションが苦手
趣味はターン卓球であーてつどうれーそね趣味は鉄道で特技は時刻表南紀と卓球でした
そして
アクティブな活動スタートの a 君は現在高校2年生
ちょっと今日は卓球の試合中らしいんですけども高校生団体の副代表もやっていて
回すいませんにとてもあふれているような印象になりました今井文化議会に不ても興味
を持っていて将来の夢だって言うけども少し変化があるようです
これは実際の話という話をしたんですけどもまぁ
ルーラーイングスという団体でこの a 君はこの団体の副代表し先ほどから何回が
登場しました
b 君は僕のことなんですけど
でとこのダイビングスっていうのは今名古屋でいろいろな活動をしていて
作る時に同じような志があったような僕と同じように変えたい
世界を変えたい日本解体国際協力をしたいそういう思いがアップのある高校生がいて
一方で a 君のようにあまり関心のなかった高校生もいました
しかし今このあいだ非常にヒアリングでちょっといろいろ聞いてみたところ
昔は新聞はスポーツランとテレビらーしか見なかった
見ないことも多かったしかし今は国際情勢が気になり色々な国際情勢の新聞の卵を見る
ようになったとか
それから本当にいほんて恵まれている国なんだなぁと本当に実感したとか
様々な変わった意見自分が変わったところを色々教えてくれて
中には国際協力の分野だけではなく
この団体に入って名刺のデザインを一緒に考えたりとか
チラシのデザインを考えていたとかする中でデザインに目覚め
デザインといいなあということでそういった大学を志すようになったとしないと思い
ます
どんどんどんどん人が変わっていくんです
今国際協力についての活動についてお話ししましたけれどもそれ以外にもまだまだごく
少数でありますが
アクティブな活動してる高校生があるので少し紹介したいと思います
この t for 3.11という団体はもう高校生が運営してるんですけど
すでに5000人以上の高校生を東北へ派遣してきましたこのほかでは企業協賛7つ
取って高校生が集めたお金で実施しました
つまり高校生によって5000
人以上の高校生の価値観だとか考え方を変えたわけですね
今国際理解東北支援てきましたけどもそれだけではなく政治的活動をしている高校生も
います
これこの t 4 sweat t な5分ベントという団体なんですけれども
は18歳選挙権についてもっと普及させていこうとそういう活動していますまあ少し
だけ前に遡ると18歳選挙権がニュースとかで話題になっていること
も多かったんですけども
東北の復興支援に氏を政治関係にしろそういった分野でのスキルを高校生が磨き
そしてそれを将来社会に活かすことができるととてもそれは素晴らしいことなんじゃ
ないかなと思っています
高校生のアクティブ革命は偏差値競争
そういったものだけでなくアクティブ競争は競争するだけず競争なんてねしなくても
いいかもしれませんがもっともっと別の分野
もっと別のスキルそういったものをみんなで高め合えるような環境
そういった方になっていけばいいんじゃないかなと
これ
お話を聞いてくださった皆様へ
一層の高校生生活となんでしょうかそれをもう一度言って考えて頂きたいなと
それをですね
子供さんだったりまお孫さんだったりとか
まだ身の回りの校講師だとか
どんどんどんどんこれからアクティブになりたいとなった方がいいとそういうふうに
思っている高校生がいるかもしれませんがなかなか一歩を踏み出せずにいますぜひぜひ
サポートをしてほしいなとそしてお話を聞いてくださった中高生の皆さん是非
一方社会に出てみてください
そこでは
いろいろスキー
新しい夢そして仲間
そういうそれらを見つけることができます手に入れることができます
そこで出会った仲間や夢スキルというものは将来一生の宝物になるはずです
高校生の時に出会えばこれからずーっと自分についてきます
人は変わりますそれが社会を迎えます
きっかけがあれば変わるんです
先ほどずっとお話してきましたこの社会のの刺し革命というものと高校生のアクティブ
額面
この2つの要素によって僕らの青春大学名は代いたします
最後になりますが
この青春大革命に興味を持たれた方やもし一緒にやりたいという方がいればぜひ僕にご
連絡をくださいぜひコンタクトを取ってください
また冒頭へ
少しを半焼しましたけれども同時に彼女を募集していますので
同市同市ご連絡お待ちしていますありがとうございました